um I think one of the things we were
we're constantly conscious about is is
thinking about what this generational
upsurge that we're seeing with the
millennial generation and I haven't come
up with a better there's a better term
than millennial I know are on our team
or my closest millennial colleague Chris
Ophir sort of wrinkles at the topic at
the term but Chris and colleagues will
will why don't you guys come on up while
while they're making the shift maybe at
the end of this discussion we'll have a
better term for the this next gen that
the the the largest generation
increasingly online so Chris I'm gonna
hand it over to you and let you
introduce the next conversation my
colleague Chris Ophir folks all right
hey everybody my name is Christopher I
work at night foundation I guess I was
asked up here to organize slash moderate
this panel on Millennials and news as I
told the the panelists who are the the
speakers who are going to be talking to
you in in a minute I think it's a lot
less interesting to ask about the
behavior of a generation because that's
just a giant group of people and you
can't help but make hopeless
generalizations and false assumptions
about a whole generation it is however
way more interesting to think about the
behavior of people and what we can learn
from them so the four people you're
gonna hear from have done a lot of work
with people of the younger persuasion
have a really deep expertise in
different facets of that question how do
you work with younger people to do
different kinds of things have some
really interesting human centered useful
insights from their work and they're
gonna share those in the format of brief
five minute talks linear from four
people and they're gonna come up
afterward and answer some questions time
allowing so if you have questions please
hold them till the end and we can sort
of talk together about some of what
they've given us but you're gonna hear
from I'm not gonna comp in between
you're gonna hear from Tron ha formerly
a red eye in Chicago now doing a night
journalism fellowship at Stanford
University you're gonna hear from Jared
Keller from policy sorry dot mic
formerly known as policy mic you can
hear from Katie Peters of democracy
works and turbo vote and you're gonna
hear from Chris Rudd of mikvah challenge
so without further ado Tron ha
let's do a quick game of
word-association
yell out the first word you think of
when I say Millennials yeah awesome
selfie Chris Chris Topher okay
this label comes with a lot of baggage
right I've been working with young
audiences for most of my career and
usually when I mentioned this in
conversation it usually goes a little
something like blah blah blah
selfie blah blah blah Justin Bieber the
word entitlement comes up the word lazy
comes up and inevitably the phrase I
just don't get why fill in the blank so
what does the future of news and
information
woops that's a preview what does the
future of news and information look like
for this group are we destined to see
more of this or this there are plenty of
broad generalizations out there about
Millennials and as a knight fellow this
year what I really tried to understand
was why do they do what they do what
drives them what are their needs what's
important to them and I did in-depth
interviews with more than two dozen
Millennials to get at these insights one
question I asked was how do you define
news so this is John he's 23
he lives in Austin and he defines news
as something that is fact-based or is
new to me
he sees news as being more than
information received from TV radio
online newspapers and other traditional
channels
newse could be something he sees from
one of his friends on Instagram this is
Haley she's 24 and she lives in New York
she defines news as timely stories and
events that have relevance for me her
main sources of news are Facebook
Instagram and email she grew up
listening to NPR so she'll sometimes
tune into WNYC when she's in the car
she thinks the media covers too much of
the same kinds of stories and force a
man who's 24 and lives in LA something
has to be both socially and politically
relevant to meet his criteria of news it
doesn't become news to me until until I
know how it affects people
he says the man's main source of news is
Twitter and he tends to follow people
and personalities not necessarily news
organizations I want to take a look at
three prevalent millennial stereotypes
as it pertains to news and information
and do a lightning round of millennial
myth-busting so the first myth /
stereotype is that Millennials are lazy
yes they do expect news and information
to reach them where they are whether it
be on Facebook Instagram or Twitter for
example but people like John Haley and
samman are not lazy or passive consumers
they're actively creating and defining
their own content and coming of age in
an era of too much information they've
developed their own systems for
filtering the information that's
relevant to them so relevance is the key
word here if it's not relevant
it gets tuned out myth number number two
they don't have the attention span to
read or watch long form now what
surprised me about a lot of my
interviews is just how much long form
many of them do consume
Matt who's 22 and also from Austin grew
up watching 60 minutes with his parents
and he says he enjoys that in-depth
format if he hears about a news maker
who piques his interest
he'll search interviews of that person
on YouTube and binge watch them many of
the Millennials I interviewed also
listen to longer format and PR shows and
podcasts so the takeaway here is they
need to be interested in order to
consume the long form and they'll seek
out what they're interested in on their
own time the third and last myth that
I'll talk about today is they won't pay
for anything so while many of them
describe themselves as frugal and scrimp
on saving things that there are things
that they are willing to pay for samman
for example buys cheap gas station food
but will spend $9.99 a month on Spotify
Premium so I think this last insight is
really interesting as we think about
payment for content it's not that this
group is not willing to pay for anything
it's just that they have a very high bar
what they pay for has to have
significant value for them personally or
socially oh and on that note and look
forward to talking more during Q&A thank
you
[Applause]
That's not me but that could be I'm my
name is Jared Keller I'm the director of
programming at Mike we were recently
policymic until last week we rebranded
to give ourselves a brand new website
that's our new logo it's much better
than our old one the whole idea was that
we wanted a better design sensibility we
wanted to expand our coverage so
including policy in the name didn't make
much sense however despite the rebrand
our redesign our sensibilities stole the
scene we want to deliver news and
analysis to the next generation of news
consumer we want deliver stories that
matter to the next generation now what
does that next generation mean oh boy
it's Millennials yes it is so these are
all stats from Pew Research Center about
what kind of defines millennial
generation most of the fundamental
research says the same thing that were
disenfranchised with existing
institutions Social Security is a big
one since none of us will collect any
that were politically and socially
active that we have a strong sense of
justice this is all kind of con research
and every news organization should know
this backwards and forwards
however most herbs or news organizations
least corner op-ed pages say that we are
terrible terrible human beings we are
Idol trophy kids entitled lazy
superficial unable to come in unable to
really do anything of substance we don't
care about serious news or serious
issues we care about nothing unless it's
going viral or a friend shared on
Facebook which is hopelessly and
aggravatingly reductive so most media
outlets see this look at these guys
they're all smiling they have so many
aspirations and ideals they're not gonna
work hard to achieve any of them No
do we want them to care about what's
going on Egypt let's frame it in terms
of 27 shifts from Jurassic Park because
that's the only way to get them
interested in fact you know I bond here
I'm just gonna take a quick selfie if
you don't mind
great usual Millennials actually look
like hi so I don't like hearing any of
this stuff because I consume regular
news I care about what's having the
middle east I care abouts happening in
Ukraine I care about what's happening to
the health care system in the US because
it directly affects me this is the face
that I get people when they say you
don't care because you're millennial
this is my are you kidding me
face you know that it's funny there's
the Pew Research Center has all this
information there's plenty of data about
what Millennials actually consume but
time after time a lot of legacy media
outlets will run these op-eds about how
we are you know but what kind of a worst
generation ever and that will accomplish
nothing we want everything handed to us
on our plate and that's not accurate and
that's sort of what we're trying to
debunk at mic the belief that that young
people don't care about serious issues
we want to build a business that
involves delivering serious news and
topics that matter to young people now
I'm you know a lot that has to do with
the way in which we consume so I have a
bunch of charts which I also stole from
pew which I'm gonna run through so more
more people are getting their news from
social networks I think we all
understand this that more people are
turning the Facebook and Twitter and I
guess reddit although I don't know why
for more and for more and more news
you know we're consuming news in a
social context it's not just us saying
at home and consuming in a one-to-one
relationship with our newspaper our
television we're we're consuming news in
you know in a conversation in an ongoing
conversation with our friends with our
colleagues with our connections young
Americans consume more more news online
golly gee I wonder why it's cuz we all
grew up with the Internet I don't really
remember life before the Internet at all
which is terrifying and also you know
accurate and more young people consume
news on social media and this number is
increasing from hour after hour day
after day week after week and so on this
is not just the future of young people
you know the future of Millennials which
is generally used to describe a small
you know maybe seriously an age but more
of a sensibility a way of consuming news
that yeah is confined to a certain age
but isn't really about age
you know my father was a correspondent
for CBS in the Boston area gets a lot of
his news through Twitter and he liked to
joke that he's millennial because he
consumes news in the same way that
people of my generation do and he's it's
made him a better reporter although
don't tell him I said that more people
consuming news on mobile this has to go
this goes directly with the idea of
consuming on social the vast majority of
traffic to Facebook and Twitter come
from mobile sites not from a desktop so
those two go hand-in-hand here's what
young people are not reading 73% don't
read BuzzFeed 84% don't read reddit 96%
don't read Nashville or Gawker
a lot of this has to do with reading
from the home page so a lot of times
people will say oh I don't you know I
don't go to these websites but I
actually I don't click on something that
a friend shared so why should I care I
think a lot of media companies have the
idea that in order to deliver
information to the young gent into a
younger generation has to be framed the
most insipid idiotic way possible like
you know I'll give you an example you
know the you know the crisis in Egypt
explained through 27 Jeff's from
Jurassic Park that is an actual article
that was written on a website I'll let
you guess who wrote it it's the idea
that we don't like to eat our vegetables
we only like to eat sugar and because
there's so much sugar on the internet
we'll stick it out anywhere so we really
have to trick people we have to bring
them in and you know to read this this
kind of dreck and then we'll give them
something else but that's not really the
case at all our value proposition and
mike has always been that we can deliver
news in a way that makes sense to young
people
the idea is that like I said we consume
use of social context so I mean who read
as if anyone reads the presentation of
self in everyday life by my goth Minh in
college now I see one hand back there to
a couple right so you know every action
that we take is designed to present a
certain a certain portion of ourselves
basically news we consume you know the
clothes that we wear the things that we
say to people and social media has
basically made that part of our everyday
life it's not a tool that we use it's an
extension of ourselves so we think to
ourselves how do we get people to
consume this news we have to make it a
part of their identity we have to make
people click and share on something
because it resonates with their identity
because it's valuable to them as a
person who lives their life not on not
offline and then a little bit online but
who lives their life on in two different
mediums so here so I'm gonna run through
some examples of hard news stories that
we did that actually played really well
oh well here's our traffic growth - we
found that young people actually care
about serious issues surprisingly
there's not a chip in any well their
chips around here somewhere
but you know I merely on policy focused
on health care we focused on legislation
in Congress we focused on the crises
abroad in Egypt in Ukraine and Russia
and boy like the traffic numbers no lie
like people are actually interested and
this isn't just kind of like a beating
switch where we have one you know super
viral story with like the 15 cancer
every better day than you and that
generates the 18 million uniques no
these are this was all spread pretty
evenly over all of our stories so mom I
just did what no other president before
him has done I forget what it what
stories actually was I think it was
about capping co2 emissions 137 thousand
shares 2.5 million uniques I'm not
really sure that the New York Times
could say the same with all due respect
to the Times morosely shows the shocking
result when men and when women in
minorities email their professors
talking about gender and race issues on
campus 38,000 shares
1 million views Sochi problems is more
of an embarrassment for America than it
is for Russia this little media Cristal
criticism for us 87,000 chairs 2 million
views
these aren't this isn't like fluffy
stuff this isn't like 23 things that
only people who studied radical feminist
ecosystems at Vassar will understand
we're not targeting very very narrow
identities for a cheap chair we're
focusing on issues that actually matter
the young people issues of justice
International Affairs politics culture
society social and economic justice and
it's working for us somehow so what this
means for media companies lectionary
should news consumers care about serious
news vital and viral and i mutual
exclusive i've always told people that
if something is good they will share it
a good example is whose red tallahassee
coats is cover story for the atlantic on
the case reparations yeah that's like
some serious hefty and it's the
most read story in the atlantic history
you know
godless is a good example in brewery
slaughter on why women can't have it all
also a really really serious serious
issue spark touched off a major debate
about gender relations in the US you
know incredibly incredibly long but
people still read it and enjoy that a
lot of my friends were my age I'm 27 I
don't know why that matters
you don't read and enjoyed it as well
Millennials they're just like you and me
they're just like well they're just like
me because like a millennial but I think
the last thing that I'll say about this
is that no young person likes to be
identified as millennial no one's to be
spoken to as a millennial is the most
condescending thing you can say to
someone
it basically says I'm gonna put you in a
box so that I can exploit your culture
and sell you stuff just call my own
people or just say people even but the
next generation of news consumption has
everything to do with identity is
everything to do with issues that matter
and the more and more media companies
continue to put Millennials in a box and
say we can only speak to you in terms of
funny cat pictures the more we're gonna
see sort of the two-tiered system of
content that we see online we see a
bunch of new startups which generate all
sorts of funny pictures and stuff and
get all the funding and have 150 to 200
million uniques and then we see
organizations which are doing great
enterprise reporting languishing and
those two things are mutually exclusive
you can cover important issues in a way
that's accessible and meaningful young
people you just have to treat them like
people and not like young people and I
think that's it okay thanks
I think I figure that up hey everybody I
think you might have figured out already
that the theme of this panel is none of
us wanted to be on this panel but I hope
that works out all right in the end
anyway but no I actually I think I mean
it well it turns out that millennial as
Jarrod's so well Twp is not really thing
anybody wants to get called if it's
gonna look like this so I'll start with
the defense of um I swear I'm too old
for this
but but hopefully I'll manage to say
something worthwhile I was trying to
think about what would mark me as a
millennial or as a person of the
internet so to speak and the first thing
I thought of was about my parents right
you start with who you can contrast
yourself to in about 1989 they bought
our family's first Encyclopedia
Britannica and an IBM 386 and about the
same year I don't think they ever
expected the former to obviate the
latter to obviate the need for the
former I on the other hand grew up in a
way where the Google Wikipedia symbiosis
is totally natural to me I take it for
granted that I have an external memory
sitting at my fingertips 24/7
my first encyclopedia came with a game
and the fact that it was on a cd-rom as
opposed to the web doesn't really matter
much in retrospect so I'm up here
because I run a website called turbo
vote my co-founder says Flaxman is in
internet terms a touch younger than me
his first real promise that he got
bought into on technology was Amazon's
it is technology brings you stuff to
your door in the mail and so one day we
were both graduate students he came and
asked me the question of why hasn't the
internet made democracy awesome and I
thought well the answer to that question
would be that there must be like a
database of election it's happening
election rules like
information it's an information problem
you just collect it and you publish it
that must already exist right it didn't
I thought well it's the Internet it must
be really easy to just collect it and
publish it right actually it still
wasn't but I'm gonna maintain that that
was a fair assumption especially for me
as sort of a child of Google instead
what he meant though is that we would
collect it learn it and sure publish it
but also use it to send people stuff in
the mail and it actually took a lot of
work to find a publishing house capable
of taking all of the different forms and
all of the really unique copies of
things that every state requires to get
registered to vote and to submit an
absentee ballot request but we learned
to do it and we send out voter
registration forms an absentee ballot
request in the mail with stamped
addressed envelopes it's a cool service
I'm pretty proud of it but the other day
speaking of the promises of the internet
that take you by surprise that mark you
is old and no longer on the edge of it a
talk went viral in my Twitter feed in
which one of the core complaints about
big data in addition to you know all of
the invasiveness all of the unforgiven
as' of it is if you know so much about
me why can't you talk to me why do you
insist on showing me both Geico car
insurance ads and zip car ads if you
know that at least one of them can't be
relevant to my needs I was a little
shocked by that the idea that you could
demand that of Internet advertising but
this guy who technically speaking is
older than me is I think once I started
looking around on the on point I looked
at Matthew Norfleet who in 2012 was a
student body president in Eastern
Michigan University he was implementing
turbo vote on campus trying to register
his classmates to vote he looked at all
of our guidelines on sending mass emails
across an entire campus at
institutionalizing it into standard
administrative processes and said that's
boring that's not very personal
and he recruited a set of student
leaders installed our mobile website as
a shortcut on everyone's home screens
and sent them out to stock down and
register their classmates one by one hi
I'm Matt can I register you to vote we
hired him for the record
Angelica Smith was the student body vice
president at Virginia Tech University
last year again she looked at all of our
guidelines about doing mass broadcasts
about the importance of voter engagement
and said huh I bet I can top that and
she brought together a coalition of
student groups and and relationships so
that every student heard a custom
message about the importance of voting
from someone relevant to them and as I
started hearing these stories I kept
thinking about that that talk that had
that had popped through my Twitter feed
and I started thinking about what we've
been doing and actually over the course
of the last couple years we've been
doing that already our partners at
Towson University took it to something
of an extreme when they built a voter
registration golf cart I don't know if
they actually hunt down and stock
individual students with it or not I
kind of hope they don't but what I
thought of as our growing ability to
collect more information and sort more
data keep thinking in encyclopedic terms
in many ways has meant that we're able
to track additional regulations and as
we're trying to explain to people the
importance of things like which places
you can register to vote on Election Day
turns out we've had to design rules for
well how do you know who should know
about that answer we track who's sent in
their voter registration forms we know
who needs to be told about registering
an election day because they didn't get
registered in time we can make that more
personal for an individual user and the
number of ways in which we talk to
individual voters using the platform
that Astrea vote has grown exponentially
more complex and as such infinitely more
personal over the last two and a half
years of our operations it just took
sitting down and talking to those users
to realize that that's what we've really
been responding to overall this
and so I set out to build the
all-knowing all-seeing voter engagement
machine and it turns out what I've been
building is an experience that lets each
and every voter be at the center of
their own actions casting their own
ballots and speaking their own voice in
the most unique and personal way that
they know how and if there's anything
that I'm seeing coming out of my own
experience serving any one of what I'd
call the next generation the internet
that's the promise we're busy trying to
fulfill and trying to make come real
that I hope we'll all be able to take
for granted next Thanks
first thing so we have this panel
talking about Millennials and young
people and there's actually a really
young person here who would probably be
the best to talk about this than any of
us sorry I know you guys did great
but yeah so everyone now has to follow
Andrew in kurios see you RIE L he's a
new to Twitter he's super dope he's from
Florida so you guys should all follow
him right now seriously yeah and like
normal young people I would say pull out
your phones but I see everybody's on
laptop so do it on your laptop but yeah
he's super cool all right so my name is
Chris I work at mikvah challenge mikvah
is a a youth service ordinate
organization excuse me
in Chicago so we work with young people
to get them involved in the political
process the spiel my executive director
says that when you want to get young
people to be professional ballplayers
you make them practice practice practice
and then they get good right but in
America for civics or for voting we tell
them you can't be involved until you hit
18 and then we expect them to be great
at it and it just doesn't work that way
my organization focuses on getting them
involved a lot younger so then this
question about a stronger Internet and
so the question that came to me was for
what why do we need that and so for me
it's for the young people I work with to
be able to change the world that they
live in the world that we all live in
but that's that's the goal that we have
to change this thing to something better
and so when we talk about this question
of young folks it's normally by old
folks who don't understand your young
folks so and they don't understand the
way they do things and they think the
way the young people do things is wrong
because it's not the way that they did
it back in the day and so you know this
is a bunch of adults at a table and
young people have to look and that's not
the way it looks anymore so now young
people are at the table and they use
their computers they use their phones
and they create dope stuff it's crazy I
wrote all the stuff down but now I'm not
using it and they create all these great
products for them for their peers
they're super engaged the young people I
work with focused on juvenile justice
issues in in Chicago and in Cook County
and so we policymic we were we were
using that we use rap genius to annotate
juvenile justice policies in Illinois
and they were super excited because they
got to put their own flavor on boring
stuff right and so what we do I guess
they term it participatory politics we
want to get young people engaged in the
political process wherever they are at
and that is what they're doing it's not
like we invented something for them they
did it so you can be civically engaged
without necessarily going to the polls
you don't necessarily have to vote every
four years and if you are great but if
that's the only thing you're doing
you're probably messing up these young
folks are engaging every day as he said
they're sharing information they're
they're liking things they're engaging
with information with editors they're
doing all this stuff that before they
didn't have an opportunity to so we talk
about again these the older folks
they want to have it their way but the
young people are not doing it so people
are getting upset right and so young
people are still consuming information
they're still I said probably more than
any generation prior to them and now
they're able to create information at a
level unseen they get a smartphone they
get an iPod they get whatever they want
not whatever they want whatever they
have and they make stuff and they're
able to share it and they're able to
engage each other in a way that we
weren't able to do before but so it
starts with a question and the main way
you engage young people if you talk to
them you ask them questions and it's not
about engaging them where you want to
engage them but you learn to engage them
where they're at and then they'll go
forward so our question was what tools
policies and practices do you need to
positively transition from Corrections
to communion I know that's long that was
adult created but it basically means
what do young people need when they get
out of the juvenile justice system in
Chicago so one of the answers that my
young folks came up with was expunged EO
and so this is a web app to help young
people erase their criminal records we
found out that 25 thousand young people
were arrested in Chicago every year and
in 2012 70 young people filed for
expungement and were able they were
granted expungement but that's a very
very small drop in the bucket right so
my young people said this is a huge
problem and we got to do something about
it so this is what we came up against
they presented this information to
community leaders to civic leaders and
most of these folks are a little bit
older know I felt like there's gonna be
a very Aegeus conversation so I'm sorry
about that
but they had no clue what they were
talking about it didn't make sense to
them like they knew it was an issue but
they didn't understand how an app or a
web app or what was a web app like what
is that how is it two things at once
and how that could change this problem
so we spent most of the fall of 2013
trying to get people interested in this
issue
they were talking to their friends they
were on Facebook steadily tweeting out
stuff on Twitter they did all this stuff
to try to get people bring awareness to
this issue so the Internet is actually
where we we found our solutions so a
nonprofit is very hard none of us know
tech stuff like I'm not a tech person at
all I appreciate it and I love what you
guys do but I don't know how to do it
so one day I met Cassie dang at a
hackathon and she tweeted at me about
something around juvenile justice issues
and I said oh my students came with this
idea of BAM so she's like cool I'd love
to work on it so within four months we
created the app and we released it in
January of this year like very basic but
people started paying attention and now
they were starting to say oh young
people can do stuff they're not just you
know especially Chicago they're just not
killers or not they don't just they're
not lazy they they do care and it was it
was an experience so the other thing was
a lot of you know we live in America
it's a very racist country it's very
segregated and a lot of our young people
are very disenfranchised Chicago we
don't expect this from from young folks
especially young black and brown people
but through participatory politics
through this internet they're able to
engage with you with each other they're
able to engage with civic leaders so
like my students tweet at people all the
time normally not the higher-ups because
they don't control their own Twitter but
like the staffers the the number twos
and so you know they a group of young
people who normally don't have access
and the the political arena now have
access so this other thing about like
organizing I was listening to NPR piece
a week ago and they were talking about
you know this is 50th anniversary of
Freedom Summer and so you had this whole
movement to talk about civil rights and
equity and
there's this whole process there's an
organizing process and these young
people are doing that they're just not
doing the traditional way so they're
still you know they're creating
awareness campaigns through likes
through shares on Facebook it's not the
same as going out passing out flyers
they're not doing that anymore but
they're still interested I was saying
like in the 60s it takes weeks to get a
hundred some signatures maybe a few
thousand but in three days 75,000 people
sign the petition against Bank of
America like that it's just it's unseen
right and now young people are using the
Internet to mobilize and teach their
peers it said forty five percent of
youth get their news from friends or
family
it's like 49% are using traditional
media like newspapers but this is you
know this is the way that they're going
they don't I was talking to Andrew and
see expert in the room these young folks
are way more Earth's conscious than than
we are and so the young people I work
with hate using paper like they just
can't stand it so they'd rather do stuff
online because they know what this has
in regards for their future right so we
released a pin in January there was all
this buzz there big juvenile expungement
became a hot topic in Chicago and so the
mayor had to start acknowledging it so
he co-sponsored a bill for automatic
juvenile expungement in March and they
just passed the bill in June of this
year so this is you know a very quick
turnaround of young people engaged in an
issue they fought for it they shared it
with their peers and now we have policy
change that's going to affect the lives
of thousands and thousands of young
people in the future
so then why do we want a better internet
or how do we ensure that we have a
better internet and so I think to do
that we have to make sure people from
diverse backgrounds are creating what
the internet is not just what is shared
it and I think a better internet means a
possibility for a better world and
social media is part of a broader
democratizing project that empowers
communities and individuals in ways
traditional media cannot young people
can now organize themselves in society
faster than any other generation they
learn about more issues and with that
knowledge organize powerful civic
actions they topple governments in the
Middle East without drones they briefly
terrorize Wall Street etc each action
they learn and share after each action
they learn and share those lessons with
the world and we all become smarter the
other thing is that young people still
need guidance and they they they crave
it they're very talented and they're
very witty and they can do so much but
they're still young and there's lots to
learn and we still have a lot to impart
on them so to ensure a better internet
we have to teach them
digital literacy news literacy how to
critically analyze what what the world
is so that they can lay the foundation
or push it forward to have a better
world and a better internet so that's it
[Applause]
we're gonna we have a couple minutes for
questions so I'm gonna invite everybody
up Ethan is gonna kindly run the
microphone around for us I see a hand
from oh and let me say it's in the
interest of time to ask for concisely
worded questions and we'll ask our
speakers for concisely worded answers
let's go to oh sorry Ethan sees a public
um I hear you that you don't like the
stereotypes and nobody likes to be
stereotyped but you're all ducking but I
took in advance to be the point of the
of what we were trying to divine here
which are what are the real trends put
it put aside the stereotypes if you talk
about young people of the 50s that
conjures something and it's not just the
emergence of new technology it's not
just television young people the 60s
conjures something and again it's not
just color television or space travel
young people of the 80s so what are the
defining trends that you do see and and
just a couple of suggestions are
defining events the president the
current president's election was that a
defining event and when the recession
was that a defining event but what what
are the trends that you actually do see
with this generation so I work in Civic
technology specifically we're actually
seeing youth voter engagement go up so
clearly there's a real willingness to
engage in political channels again but
with a real sense that people want to
interact in ways that are relevant and I
think there's a sort of a jaded nough
cebause
channels that don't serve us well and
when I talk about the demand of
Technology and big data in ads it's this
could work better I think with politics
there's that same sense of I'm going to
get engaged but I want this to work
better and there's a real demandingness
of the institutions around us in us and
a real sense that they aren't working
well and that we don't see the channels
necessarily to automatically improve
them so there's a real willingness to
engage combined with a real fear of
being
down so I would I would say that I think
one of one of the big differences is
just how much information is out there
today for for young people and so if I
can make one broad generalization it
would be that this group is very very
savvy in terms of being able to sift
through that information and figure out
what it is that they want to engage with
I think they're incredibly resourceful
in that way and so that's what I meant
when I said that they're not they're not
passive consumers they they know what
they want they know how to get it and
then they also know how to cross-check
it with other sources to figure out if
they want to figure out whether it's
accurate or not and they might not
always do that you know a piece of news
might not always be important enough for
them to do that but in the times that it
is they know how to do that I think
there's probably a bigger emphasis on
identity formation with this generation
there's been maybe during any other time
in American history with the exception
of Revolutionary War which is all about
identity formation I guess and then also
the 60s and 70s but you know I mean
there are more tools at our disposal to
kind of generate these identities in the
past you're sort of self is defined by
your associations I'm a member of this
of this but you know I go to this
bowling club or I work in this job or I
associate with these people now because
sort of energies of Association are cut
down by the internet and by social media
every action is an act like a
deformation so it's not just so even the
act of consuming news has become what
does it say about me people will share
things often people will share things on
their Facebook or Twitter pages that
they haven't even read because it says
something smart about them it says I'm
the sort of person who reads Harper's
even though I didn't actually read
anything in Harper's ever and because of
this you know everything is is it's
couched in identity so in order to get
important issues important important
topics in the news you know laws
legislation in Congress you know
Brod the question is always how does
this affect me and was this mean for my
future as a human being not just as you
know a member of the group as an
American or as or as whatever or as a
young person but for me personally was
this mean for my route to self
self-actualization and I think that
often gets taken as a sign of narcissism
because we talked about oh you just you
know go find a job that makes you happy
which a lot people tell their kids from
the Graduate College and is totally
unrealistic speaking of someone who's
had jobs that have made me not happy but
you know I mean there's because there
are so many more avenues then taking a
job or or becoming a member of a Friars
Club or something that allows you to
construct your identity an associate of
different people I think there's more of
a more of an emphasis put on it on day
to day activity I'd say one thing this
when you term a group of people that the
divide is so big so like if you're say
millenniums you talk about like 15 to 20
something that's a very different group
of people to say what do they want to do
it they're not unified in that aspect
the other thing is try so before it's
it's about interests so and you know
it's hard to say what each one is
interested in they're all interested in
different stuff but that is what they
will share that is what they will read
that is what they will do stuff that
interests them and I would disagree that
it's it's always about identity with
that demographic with teenagers it's all
about figuring out who they are
that is the point in their life when
they do that they're trying to figure
out who they are and their friends have
so much to do with that it's no longer
adults it's it's their peer group so I
think one way that we engage young
people better particularly with news is
that you have more young people writing
what we consider news some I think a lot
of it it's going to be has to be a
change in the definition of what news is
and the people who traditionally got to
define that can no longer do it and we
have to accept that
hi sorry Amy kalila I'm Stanford
d.school I'm wondering to what extent
does the terminology in the conversation
Millennials need to change I really
enjoyed your point on we don't want to
be on this panel you know it's sort of
like that really brings up I think a
fundamental point like what how what
other words do we need to use I saw on
Twitter like you know we're young money
we're not Millennials like what what you
know what are we you know like what what
what other words do we need a suggestion
yeah I mean I'll just say real quick
that Millennials is not really like an
actual phrase I mean it wasn't a
marketing term teenager was invented in
the 50s as a marketing term you know
teenagers didn't exist before but before
the 1950s which is like the ludicrous to
think about I'll just say young people
you know I'm you know I mean if you
really have to but then again we're also
getting into the thing or into the
question that it's it's now being
defined generation generationally rather
than the way people consume so I mean
the way we the way we talk about it
internally at our company is we don't
say more like Millennials we're gonna
refer after Millennials you want to ask
those Millennials cuz none of us
identifies Millennials even though I put
myself up there as Millennials really
look like it's more of a question of
what does the next generation of news
consumer and that's couldn't gonna be
everyone from someone who's just
entering high school to you know my
grandmother who's amazing on Twitter I
think Chris made a really good point in
terms of you know this is a really broad
group of people you're talking about
you're talking about like 15 plus years
that separate the youngest to the to the
oldest and so I would think about more
looking at their life stages and even
beyond the life stages segmenting them
you know based on their their interests
or psychographic information it's it's
really tricky when you're trying to do
like broad strokes generalizations of a
group of people who are you know 15
years of heart especially in that part
of their lives where things are changing
so quickly
great well I think we're at a time
applause for all of our great speakers
here thank you also for the questions